it looks like 90 day fiance star big ed
has finally found the one right now big
ed's focus is on local love the reality
star is reportedly engaged to his
girlfriend liz i want to get this right
like i really i'm ready for love big
head's ready for love
tmz reports that the 55 year old and his
28 year old leading lady were spotted at
a nightclub in santa barbara california
last week and published a snap of liz
sporting a ring on her left ring finger
in a group pick with ed according to the
outlet the couple confirmed they were
engaged to other club-goers and ed was
introducing liz to people as his quote
beautiful fiancee the rest is history et
has reached out to tlc for comment but
get this
an eti witness caught the two kissing at
a santa barbara train station over the
weekend that's the couple packing on the
pda and smooching it up
it was kind of surreal it was absolutely
surreal ed first rose to fame on season
4 of 90 day fiance before the 90 days
when he traveled to the philippines to
meet rose after they connected online
i want to be your man yeah you're a man
you're my king michael i'm her king
she's my queen she ended up breaking up
with him and ed later starred in 90 day
the single life where he pursued liz
i'm probably the first person in history
to ever to be able to break out of the
friend zone and
now i want liz to be my girlfriend it's
nerve-wracking i'm nervous
but during the 90-day the single life
tell-all in may ed and liz said they
broke up
i didn't want to lose him and i still
lost him
liz got emotional saying ed rushed the
relationship and that he went to las
vegas and hung out with other women just
two days after they broke up you blocked
me and went to vegas and ranted about
your sugar babies i didn't expect to be
dumped and then him be out in vegas
living the life
yeah and he didn't deny it and despite
his fellow 90-day fiance cast members
urging liz to move on she said she
wanted to get back together
she also wasn't fazed when her 90-day
cast member fernanda called ed out
alleging that he tried to hit on her 26
year old roommate
i've missed ed a lot this last month as
far as the future we were talking about
it earlier i still want to be with him
but
he's pushed me away so many times that
when we were talking earlier
i told him like if we were to give it a
fair chance it has to be
a fair chance
as for ed he said he was still in love
with liz and wanted to go to therapy
together
i'm committing to how many ever it will
take
for me to get you back and for me to fix
my [ __ ] i love you liz when she walked
in here it just
i froze
i was knocked off my rock arriving
seniors since we broke up a month ago
today the minute i yeah the minute she
started talking i'm like i'm screwed
because i'm in love
that's a good thing actually but before
all that e.t spoke to ed in february
where he explained what he's looking for
when it comes to love they have to be
pretty i mean obviously but they also
have to have a big heart and they have
to be kind and they have to be positive
um
and secure about who they are because
because big head comes with some baggage
i mean i'm i i have insecurities you
know i'm a little bit jealous i'm a
little bit insecure because i've been
out of the dating scene so long like i
don't know how to be in a relationship
and so those are the challenges that i'm
i'm running into
[Music]